what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i am going
to be reacting to taylor swift back to
december from like a red pill um
perspective
um before i start don't forget to
subscribe to the channel as you guys
know i'm moving to england in a couple
weeks and each and every one of you
subscribing helps the channel and helps
me grow
okay
[Music]
i'm so glad you made time to see me
how's life tell me as your family
i haven't seen them in a world
[Music]
you've been good
[Music]
okay so
she broke up with him
this is taylor lautner and back in the
early 2000s every girl was obsessed with
taylor lautner so i have no idea what
she was thinking
[Music]
standing in front of you saying i'm
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what
[Music]
okay so basically this is her realizing
that the grass isn't greener on the
other side so they talk about this in
hypergamy where
um girls basically like break up with
their husbands or like the person
they're supposed to be with like they
wreck their own home
i don't know if that's actually what
happened but because i think she was
pretty young when she wrote this song
but that's how she feels
[Music]
these days i haven't been sleeping
staying up playing back myself
[Music]
the dark days
[Music]
okay so this is what the manosphere
talks about like all the time how
guys when they do exactly what the girl
wants and they give everything to her
like then the girl doesn't want him
anymore
so
she's saying like you gave me roses you
did all this nice stuff aka simping and
then you were like nah i don't want it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i go back to december
[Music]
september
[Music]
again
[Music]
i heard lyrics are so beautiful i don't
care what anyone says that is beautiful
if we loved again i swear i'd love you
right like that
poet poetry
but yeah this is her realizing she
fumbled the back
[Music]
but this is me swallowing my pride
standing in front of you saying i'm
sorry for that
back to night
[Music]
[Music]
december all the time
[Music]
oh no she wrote the letter from her
all right let me know in the comments if
your ex wrote you a song like this would
you go back
if she just said look i'm sorry i
fumbled the bag
would you would you give her a second
chance let me know in the comments um
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
ring that notification
bell and i will talk to you guys next
time